العالم وعلى بعد خطوات من ازمات متداخله
بين شتاء قاسم دق اب وبدور
ثمن عوده ارتفاع اصابه فايروس كورونا مع
شتاء هذا العام الاول الذي يتخلى خلاله
العالم عن القيود التي فرضتها الجائحه
في مواجهه تلك التغيرات اجراءات استثنائيه
في امريكا
بعد الارتفاع الملحوظ في عدد الاصابات
بلغت وفقا لاخر الاحصائيه الرسميه
من الولايات المتحده للصين واحده من اخر
الدول التي تخلت تدريجيا عن سياسه صفر
كافت اعادت لتحذر مجددا من ضربه جديده
للفيرس مع ارتفاع الاصابات المتزامنه مع
الشتاء
واسطه تعبئه كبيره للمستشفيات والتوسع في
مرافق العنايه المركزه واضافه موظفين
لضمان فاعليه المستشفيات وزياده امدادات
الادويه وفقا لوسائل الاعلام الحكوميه
بريطانيا هي الاخرى باتت في شباك الشتاء
صعب عطلت معه بشكل شبه كامل وشله حركه
السكان والمرافق الصحيه شتاء ضرب قطاع
الطيران في بريطانيا
في تاريخ الخدمات الصحيه
مع ارتفاع عدد المصابين في المستشفيات
بنسبه 22% خلال اسبوع وفقا لبي في الصحه
الوطنيه البريطانيه امر دفع الجهات
المختصه في اكتوبر الماضي للاستعداد بغرف
حربيه تعتمد على البيانات لما وصفته باصعب
شتاء في التاريخ رغم ان ارتفاع عدد
الاصابات الشتاء امر متوقع اوسط منظمه
الصحه العالميه بالعوده لاجراءات قرون
الاحترازيه والحصول على الجرعات الثلاث
للالقاح قرون وكذلك لقاح الانفلونزا